I've spent nearly two decades observing
what makes people luckier than others
and trying to help people increase their
luck
you see I teach entrepreneurship and we
all know that most new ventures fail and
innovators and entrepreneurs need all
the luck they can get so what is luck
luck is defined as success or failure
apparently caused by chance apparently
that's the operative word it looks like
it's chance because we rarely see all
the levers that come into play to make
people lucky but I've realized by
watching so long that luck is rarely a
lightning strike isolated and dramatic
it's much more like the wind blowing
constantly sometimes it's calm and
sometimes it blows in gusts and
sometimes it comes from directions that
you didn't even imagine so how do you
catch the winds of luck it's easy but
it's not obvious so I'm going to share
some things three things with you that
you can do to build a sail to capture
the winds of luck the first thing you
want to do is to change your
relationship with yourself be willing to
take small risks that get you out of
your comfort zone now when we're
children we do this all the time we have
to do this if we're gonna learn how to
walk or talk or ride a bike or even
quantum mechanics right we need to go
from someone one-week who doesn't ride a
bike - next week someone who does and
this requires us to get out of our
comfort zone and take some risks the
problem is as we get older we rarely do
this we sort of lock down the sense of
who we are and don't stretch anymore now
with my students I spend a lot of time
giving them encouragement to get out of
their comfort zone and take some risks
how do I do this well I start out by
having them fill out a risk ometer now
it's basically a fun thing we developed
in our class where they map out what
risks they're willing to take and it
becomes clear very quickly to them that
risk taking is not binary they're
intellectual risks and physical risks
and financial risks and emotional risks
and social risks and ethical risks and
political risks and once they do this
they compare their risk profiles with
others and they quickly realize that
they're all really different I then
encourage them to stretch to take some
risks that get them out of their comfort
zone for example I might ask them to do
an intellectual risk and try to tackle a
problem they haven't tried before or a
social risk talking to someone sitting
next to them on the train or an
emotional risk maybe telling someone
they really care about how they feel I
do this myself
all the time about a dozen years ago I
was on an airplane early early morning
flight on my way to Ecuador and I was um
normally I would just put on my
headphones and go to sleep wake up do
some work but I decided to take a little
risk and I started conversation with the
man sitting next to me I introduced
myself and I learned that he was a
publisher interesting we ended up having
a fascinating conversation I learned all
about the future of the publishing
industry so that's three quarters away
through the through the flight I decided
to take another risk and I opened up my
laptop and I shared with him a book
proposal I was put together for
something I was doing in my class and he
was very polite he read it and he said
you know what Tina this isn't right for
us but thank you so much for sharing
it's okay that risk didn't work out shut
my laptop the end of the flight we
exchanged contact information a couple
of months later I reached out to him and
I said mark would you like to come to my
class I'm doing a project on reinventing
the book the future of publishing he
said great I'd love to come so he came
to my class we had a great experience
few months later I wrote him again this
time I sent him a bunch of video clips
from another
project by students had done he was so
intrigued by one of the projects the
students had done he thought there might
be a book in it and he wanted to meet
those students now I have to tell you I
was a little bit hurt right I mean he
wanted to do a book with my students and
not with me but ok it's all right so I
invited him to come down and he and his
colleagues came to Stanford and those
met with the students and afterwards we
have lunch together and one of his
editors said to me hey have you ever
consider writing a book I said funny you
should ask and I pulled out the exact
same proposal that I had showed his boss
a year earlier within two weeks I had a
contract and within two years the book
had sold over a million copies around
the world now you might say oh you're so
lucky but of course I was lucky but that
luck resulted from a series of small
risks I took starting with saying hello
and anyone can do this no matter where
you are in your life no matter where you
are in the world no matter even if you
think you're the most unlucky person you
can do this by taking little risks that
get you out of your comfort zone you
start building a sail to capture luck
the second thing you want to do is to
change your relationship with other
people you need to understand that
everyone who helps you on your journey
is playing a huge role in getting you to
your goals and if you don't show
appreciation not only are you not
closing the loop but you're missing an
opportunity when someone does something
for you they're taking that time that
they could be spending on themselves or
someone else and you need to acknowledge
what they're doing now I run three
fellowship programs at Stanford and
they're very competitive to get into and
when I send out the letters to those
students who don't get in I always know
they're going to be people who were
disappointed
some of the people who were disappointed
send me notes complaining some of them
send notes saying what could I do to
make myself more successful next time
around and every once in a while someone
sends me a note
thanking me for the opportunity this
happened about seven years ago a young
man named Brian sent me a beautiful note
saying I know I've been rejecting sub
this program twice but I want to thank
you for the opportunity I learned so
much through the process of applying I
was so taken by the graciousness of his
message that I invited him to come and
meet me and we spent some time chatting
and cooked up an idea for an independent
study project together he was on the
football team at Stanford and he decided
to do a project on looking at leadership
in that context we got to know each
other incredibly well through that
quarter and he took the project that you
started working on in the independent
study and turned it altima T into a
company called play for tomorrow where
he teaches kids from disadvantaged
backgrounds how to essentially craft the
lives they dream to live now the
important thing about this story is that
we both ended up catching the winds of
luck as a result of his thank you note
but it was the winds that we didn't
expect in the first place over the
course of the last couple of years I've
come up with some tactics for my own
life to help me really foster
appreciation my favorite is it at the
end of every single day I look at my
calendar and I review all the people I
met with and I send thank-you notes to
every single person it only takes a few
minutes but at the end of every day I
feel incredibly grateful and
appreciative and I promise you it has
increased my luck so first you need to
take some risks and get out of your
comfort zone second you need to show
appreciation and third you want to
change your relationship with ideas most
people look at new ideas that come their
way and they judge them that's a great
idea or that's a terrible idea but it's
actually much more nuanced ideas are
neither good and bad and in fact in the
seeds of terrible ideas are often
something truly remarkable one of my
favorite exercises in my classes on
creativity is to help students foster an
attitude of looking at terrible ideas
and the lens through the lens
possibilities so I give them a challenge
to create an idea for a brand new
restaurant they have to come up with the
best ideas for a new restaurant and the
worst ideas for a new restaurant so the
best ideas are things like a restaurant
on a mountaintop you know with a
beautiful sunset or a restaurant on a
boat with a gorgeous view and the
terrible ideas are things like a
restaurant in a garbage dump
or a restaurant with terrible service
it's really dirty or a restaurant that
serves cockroach sushi so they hand all
the ideas to me I read the great ideas
out loud and then I rip them up and
throw them away I then take the horrible
ideas and redistribute them each team
now has an idea that another team
thought was horrible and their challenge
is to turn it into something brilliant
here's what happens within about 10
seconds someone says this is a fabulous
idea and they have to about three
minutes before they pitch the idea to
the class so the restaurant in the
garbage dump what does that turn into
well they collect all the food from
Michelin star restaurants that was going
to get thrown out all the extra food and
they have another restaurant at a much
lower price with all the leftovers
pretty cool or the restaurant that's
dirty with terrible service well that
turns into a restaurant that's a
training ground for future restaurant
tours to figure out how to avoid all the
pitfalls and the restaurant with
cockroach sushi well of course it turns
into a sushi bar with all sorts of
really interesting and exotic
ingredients if you look around at the at
the companies the ventures that are
really innovative around you the ones
that we now take for granted that have
changed our life well you know what they
all started out as crazy ideas they
started ideas that then when they pitch
to other people most people said that's
crazy it will never work so yes
sometimes people were born into terrible
circumstances and sometimes luck is a
lightning bolt that hits us with
something one
or something terrible but the winds of
luck are always there and if you're
willing to take some risks if you're
willing to really go out and show
appreciation and you're willing to
really look at ideas even if they're
crazy through the lens of possibilities
you build a bigger and bigger sail to
catch the winds of luck thank you
[Applause]